This is Disaster
Psychiatry and
Post-Traumatic
Stress Disorder.
This talk will be
in two parts. This
is part one on
disaster psychiatry.
As appeared in the Los
Angeles Times
back in January,
15 days after fire
ripped through Pacific
Palisades, destroying
his house, reducing
a good part of his
school to rubble.
This high school
senior pulled up to the
kitchen table of his
temporary Brentwood home,
logged into his laptop,
and launched Zoom.
Here we go again,
said the Palisades
Charter High School
senior, who spent
most of his middle
school in virtual
classes during COVID
-19 pandemic and
started out high
school wearing a mask
and taking weekly
coronavirus tests.
I wonder if people will
be on camera, he said.
So what are the risk
factors for this individual
and others like him
for developing a
mental health condition
as a result of the
wildfire disaster this
past January in California?
what interventions
can you provide early
on that's what we're
going to delve in right
now as you kind of
take this journey with
me on how people respond
to trauma who's at
risk for developing
traumatic stress what are
psychological first
aid and interventions
that you can provide to
a disaster situation.
And in part two, we'll
look at post-traumatic
stress disorder and
how to screen for it
and what are options
for initial management.
But in terms
of a disaster,
the initial mental
health intervention
basically comes
down to protect,
direct, and connect.
Can we protect the
person from further
injury, from further
exposure? Can
we direct them to
resources, direct
them to safety?
Can we connect them
to loved ones if
they're separated,
connect them to,
again, resources,
and can connect them
to the help that
they might need? So
the whole initial
mental health
intervention revolves
around Protect,
Direct, Connect, PDC.
I also refer you to
the CPG guide, which
will give some
additional materials.
But in terms of
disaster, a disaster is
a severe disruption,
ecological,
psychosocial, which
greatly exceeds the coping
capacity of the
affected community.
that's the world
health organization
definition um and
certainly we we saw uh some
of this with the pandemic
that we just went
through just a few
years ago uh where
the coronavirus uh you
know affected everyone
worldwide and was
what was very unique
the strangest thing
about the coronavirus
is and it ran
counterintuitive that we
couldn't really help
one another through it
we were not able to
lay on hands we could
only wash them in fact
we were explicitly
told to stay away
from one another which
made epidemiological
sense but drove us crazy.
The social distancing,
the quarantining,
the isolation, it ran
against the instinct
that made us who we
are. And in fact, with
every other time
we faced a natural
disaster, we came together.
That was the natural,
inevitable human
response to a crisis.
In the wake of an
earthquake, a *******,
a storm, most people
are altruistic. They're
urgently engaged in
caring for themselves
and those around them,
as well as friends
and loved ones. But
with coronavirus,
none of that
was possible.
In fact, the only way
to actually help was
to avoid one another.
Hence the social
distancing, the
quarantining, the
constant bombardment
of the media, the
fear of the unknown,
etc.
And even the
places that we
would gather,
you know, for
relief, for
solace, we're off
limits, churches,
schools, etc.
And
obviously, there were
things that one can
do to counteract the
effect of social isolation
and quarantining in
terms of keeping a
structure, limiting
media exposure, and
connecting via video,
phone, and video chat.
We quell anxiety
with bonding
and connecting to
others. When we
look at disasters
themselves,
we could divide
them up into
human cores and
natural cores.
Here's some video of
hurricanes in the Gulf,
the tsunamis.
and when we focus on
disaster psychiatry
we're talking about what
is the epidemiological
approach to understanding
and treating
the effects of mass
casualty situations
so this is the sort
of a timeless diagram
of sort of the taking
the community into
consideration of the
psychological psychological
uh mental health
effect of what people
go through during a
disaster um we could
let's take a look uh
consider um the recent
wildfires right um
there were there was
warnings that um wildfires
might be um happening
and uh and the fire
warnings were high
So there was a lot
of pre-disaster
warning. There was
a lot of threat.
And people were
preparing and were
ready in some instances.
In some instances,
they weren't. And
then suddenly,
really, in just a
matter of hours,
the fire, which was
far away, all of a
sudden encroached
on your home, your
neighborhood, and you have
the impact. And we saw
heroic acts of people
pulling together,
helping each
other, helping
people who were
less fortunate,
who were less
mobile, evacuate.
We saw tremendous
efforts, you know, among
our first responders.
and even during
and then right after
this sort of community
cohesion of donations
of resources of
everything sort of
flooding to the area.
And then comes the period
of this disillusionment
where no matter
how many resources
and no matter how much
preparation we did
still could not match
the overwhelming impact
of the disaster. I
just want to quickly go
back to the idea that
this disruption, the
wildfire, was so great
that it exceeded the
coping capacity of the
affected community.
um and then finally
uh and this may take
years later uh
getting back to that
equilibrium where
things are rebuilt
reconstructed or
reconfigured what happens uh
during the disaster
uh and afterwards um
when whole communities
are destroyed if
you know if if there
is the inadequate
infrastructure to
begin with, roads are
damaged, facilities
are closed, doctors are
unavailable, there
might be inadequate
transportation,
there's no 911 service.
And back to the
dialysis issue,
if hemodialysis
outpatient centers are
destroyed or flooded
or burned or knocked
out during a hurricane,
they may even
be unable to have
dialysis. This actually
is, these are the
disruption of medical
services that occurred
after Hurricane
Maria, as a reference
to the New England
Journal medical
article about this.
The key concepts of a
disaster impact, no one
who sees a disaster
is untouched by it. So
in the inner circle,
you have the primary
victims who experienced
and lived through it.
You have secondary
victims, which might be
the extended family
and friends and loved
ones of those primary
victims, as well as the
first responders who
have seen and witnessed
tremendous horrors.
And then the tertiary
victims would be people
further away who are
watching it or hearing
about it and have some
connection perhaps
with the disaster area.
but they're further
out in the concentric
circles of disaster
victims. When we look
at trauma for communities,
there's certainly
the individual trauma,
but right now in
terms of disaster
impact, we're talking
about the collective
trauma that damages the
bonds and social fabric
of the community.
And as such, we'll see
fatigue, irritability,
family conflict.
and again as we showed
you before people
pull together in the
beginning during and
right after there's a
high lot of activity uh
maybe not very efficient
but that you know
a lot of things are
getting pulled together
uh then soon after
the very normal stress
normal grief you're
reacting normally to
an abnormal situation
and then come the
emotional reactions relate
to problems of living
right there's
abnormal and excessive
disruptions to routine
routine is disrupted
after a disaster and
we're sort of all anchored
in our routines we
have a daily routine
how we get up how we
go to school or work,
you know, we have very
structured, routine
lives. It creates a
sense of security that
is all shattered as a
result of a disaster.
In terms of,
again, providing
mental health
services, people
don't typically
seek them out.
And mental health
services are practical
rather than psychological.
right practical
protect direct connect uh
so what are the critical
disaster stressors
right um again think
think of the wildfire
the the the high risk
the high stress um
events for people who
experience the the
wildfire where their whole
communities out the
dino was destroyed right
were situations where
there was a threat
to one's life. There
was a threat to
harm, destruction of
a home or community,
loss of schools,
loss of home, loss
of any sense of that
routine, that
structure, that security
that you had when
your whole town
is completely like
wiped off the map.
And remember, many
patients, many citizens
during the wildfires,
if you follow them,
didn't know if they
needed to evacuate
or were told to
evacuate and not to,
not being able to
make that decision in
a timely way. Some
were even trapped.
And then with all
the smoke and the
aftermath of the
fire, living with
with uncertainty
about what the
long range impact
is is going to be.
um there was uh a
very just uh you know
for the perfect storm
as it were right
uh in that time in
january there was
prolonged drought there
was an exceptionally
dry winter there were
powerful santa ana
winds and they set
up a dangerous set
of extreme conditions
fueling out of control
of wildfires in the
Los Angeles era.
They claimed the lives
of 29 people. There
were more than 16,000
structures destroyed.
And these type of
disasters are only
set to become
more frequent and
intense as we see
climate change
driving warmer and
drier conditions.
And there are areas
in the western u.s
mexico brazil east
africa according to
nasa that have fire
seasons that last more
than a month longer
than they did 35
years ago so this is
a serious problem and
people look at
this well are these
incidents naturally
caused or are
do they have a
human component.
And we get into the
debate of whether
wildland, urban cities
should interface
right up against
wildlands. Should
communities be built
right up against wildlands
in that wildland
urban interface?
And then was the proper
infrastructure in
place to fight a
wildfire? Because this
is not the typical
urban environment.
So the idea is, well,
people understand
and are able to better
deal with a disaster
when it occurs
naturally, you know, but
when they feel that
there's some human fault
involved, that there's
a human element, that
there's something that
was neglected, it,
then it's a lot
harder for people
to get past that
disaster situation.
So again, yeah, what
influences recovery?
Whether the disaster was
natural versus
human caused.
What's the degree of
personal impact? How
much did it affect your
daily life? The size
and scope and severity
event. the probability
of recurrence, and
community disruption
and destruction with
personal loss. I think
if you take all these
five factors and put
them up against the
California wildfires that
occurred in LA, you'll
see that there is a
big, significant impact
for each of these.
When you're dealing
with a disaster
situation and people
are missing or
you found out that
the person died as
a result of it, that
has mental health
implications, that
notification. When
search and recovery
are concluded,
if there's someone
criminally responsible
and that person is
held accountable and
proceedings occur, that
could be a trigger for
mental health issues.
And when you go back
to the impacted area,
I want to, again,
refer you to the CPG
is a nice link to one
of the firefighters
and his first responder
experience, also going
back to his home.
the reactions to
a disaster cover
four domains they
could be cognitive,
emotional, behavioral
and physical
the cognitive reactions
are trouble concentrating,
difficulty making
decisions preoccupied
with the event,
questioning spiritual
beliefs emotional could
be feeling anxiety
panic overwhelmed
behavioral can run the gamut
of sleep problems
hypervigilance not eating
of crying easily again
cognitive emotional
and a behavioral.
Just because you have
these reactions, these
so-called symptoms,
remember these are
all normal reactions
to an abnormal event.
Physical reactions
include headaches,
GI distress,
fatigue, exhaustion,
decreased appetite,
hypertension,
increased heart rate
and also remember
that if there is a
mental health or acute
change in mental status
consider is it due
to the fact that the
person is dehydrated
is it due to the fact
that they've lost
their medications is
it due to the fact
that there's a head
injury or a subdural
hematoma, are they
exposed to toxic toxins
that were released?
You know, again,
California wirefire,
wildfire, you know, a
lot of building
elements were burned,
right? Are there toxins
that were released?
Because they were
off medication,
are they going
through withdrawal?
So always consider that
in your differential.
So this gives you a
very good illustration
of some of the physical
reactions to a disaster.
This goes back to
9-11 and where they
surveyed during 2001
and 2002 nationally and
locally. And you'll
see that, for instance,
feeling fatigue
remained a year later,
rapid heartbeat
dizziness remained
a year later,
problems with
sleep a year later,
headaches continued.
So there is a physical
and physiologic
memory of the result
of trauma that kind
of stays with you.
So another
illustration of that is
seven years after
the Oklahoma City
Federal Building was
bombed, survivors
had higher heart
rates before,
during, and after
reminders of the event
than affected control
subjects, right?
So just taking a
baseline of the
survivors, elevated
heart rate,
showing them a
reminder, increase the
heart rate, and
then post-test,
maintaining that
increased heart rate. So
there is a physiologic
memory that stays
with the person well
after the disaster.
your key concepts
the target population
is normal we want to
avoid mental health
labels we want to be
innovative innovative
and offering help and
fitting the program
into the community
context a quick run
through special
populations i'm just we're
going to hit some a
few highlights here.
Among children,
separation from
parents is very key, is
a key risk factor.
The child that's
separated from their
parents during the
disaster has a higher
risk of going on to
develop mental health
issues. And also,
kids, watch your
reaction to the
disaster. You are the
role models for kids
and young people that
are in your care.
Also, what is the
pre-disaster mental
health of the child if
they're well-adjusted
before versus not
well-adjusted? The not
well-adjusted mental
health of the child
might be a risk factor
for further regression
and deterioration
after a disaster.
So it's very important
about how you
communicate with
your child about what
happened, about what
they believed caused it,
and of course the
degree which the child
was directly impacted
by the disaster.
Again, I think about
our high school senior
that we discussed during
the cold open, and
whether he says,
oh, here we go
again, hearkening
back to how
he felt in middle
school, where
He became disconnected
from his school,
had to go on Zoom
and wear the mask.
So it brings
back memories.
Look at what we
see in school-aged
children in
terms of physical
complaints and
emotional complaints.
These are workbooks
that are very good for
young children. This
was developed by Mercy
Corps after Hurricane
Katrina, but I've seen
these for all types
of disaster where it
gets the child to be
ability to process and
express rather than
holding on to those
feelings. what was the
most confusing thing the
scariest thing um
the something uh the
saddest thing i saw was
something i heard grown
-ups say was and again
maybe it's something
terrible like oh uh you
know my dog is gonna
burn or uh i i feel
like i'm gonna die
maybe that's something
that they heard and that
scared them um and the
idea also of putting
in something positive
some people were
doing really good things
to help others one
good thing that was
happened so it kind of
reframes the child
really like that um and
again this pertained to
the hurricane but you
could how i want my
uh wildfire story to
end how i want my
earthquake story to end um
write or draw a
picture of self now and
imagine how you'd like
to be in the future.
So these kind
of workbooks are
really excellent
for children.
Older adults also have a
significant
impact of losses.
Intense grief over
loss of mementos, pets.
Of course, they
might be unable
to start over or
feel that way.
Past losses
are reawakened.
We spoke about that
with the high school
senior. That applies
to adults as well.
And of course,
again,
there are
stress symptoms.
People with mental
illness have the
same basic needs
as everyone else.
um they may
even rise to the
occasion in terms
of helping uh they
sometimes we're
able to train
consumers people with
mental illness to
be part of the preparedness
process to really
empower them they
should be given the
opportunity to serve
the larger community
Special group are
the first responders,
the emergency
medical service
workers, the voluntary
agencies, the
law enforcement,
the fire service.
They have unique
stressors because at the
same time, they may
live locally and they
have to make sure
that their family and
their homes and their
possessions are safe.
And they kind of
sacrifice it in this
conflicting role of
helping the larger disaster
response. So they
have conflicting
roles. They're exposed
to chaos, death, and
destruction, the long
days of exhaustion,
the community reactions.
Initially, they might
be seen as heroes. But
later on, when services
aren't coming fast
enough and the
disasters overwhelm the
resources, they might be
blamed or scapegoated.
So when you're in and
providing disaster
relief, you need to
monitor your needs.
You need to take
regular breaks. You
need to also have
some piece of normalcy
in your routine, in
your life during the
disaster period, so
that you could kind
of re-energize and
be able to provide
the support to others
that you need to.
We talk about the
mnemonic halt. So
if you're hungry,
angry, lonely,
or tired during a
disaster event, it's
time to step back,
take a break,
and then come
back later when
you're kind of recharged.
Psychological
first aid is the
key in terms of
helping people,
promoting safety,
calm, connectedness,
self-efficacy, and hope.
And the don'ts are
telling people what
you think they should
be feeling. The
don'ts are we don't
force people to
share stories or
give us your details.
We don't make promises
that can't be kept
or tell people, oh,
you know, I think you
suffered because you
had this personal belief
or behavior. And lastly,
and very important,
and you see this a lot
with the wildfires,
is the different
agencies and government
officials and others
each criticizing existing
services and relief
activities in front
of the people that
need these services.
That could be very, very
demoralizing. There's
plenty of time for
an afterwards review.
Is there a role
for medications?
Maybe in terms of
maybe helping someone
for sleep or help
reduce their anxiety.
But generally,
again, we think of
this as a normal
reaction to an abnormal
event. And we
avoid, you know,
coming out with our
prescription pads
in the immediate
aftermath of a disaster
and medicating
patients. And there's
no evidence that
giving a benzodiazepine
to someone in the
aftermath of a disaster
has any protective
benefit with
developing post-traumatic
stress disorder.
So here's our summary.
Rescue workers and
mental health teams play
a vital role in
ameliorating the mental
health problems of
disaster survivors through
being aware of the
risk factors. screen,
initiate the
mental health
intervention, protect
direct connect,
and apply psychological
first aid.
And in part two,
we're going to
go on to the
individual with a
discussion on post
-traumatic stress
disorder. This
concludes part one.
Okay,
we've come out on
the other side of
disaster. And now
we're going to talk
about post-traumatic
stress disorder.
Post-traumatic stress
disorder is listed
under the trauma and
stress-related series
of disorders that
appear in the DSM.
It originally was
listed under anxiety
disorder. and
actually post
-traumatic stress
disorder is a fairly
recent diagnosis
that was added to the
DSM. It was actually
added in 1980.
So although it's been
around a long time
and had all different
names, especially
after World War I
and II, the shell
shock, and it goes
even further back
Then that, after the
Civil War, we saw
combat-related trauma.
But in 1980, the
APA, American
Psychiatric Association,
developed a criteria
for post-traumatic
stress disorder. And
it ushered in the
concept, the stipulation
that the etiologic
agent was outside
of the individual as
opposed to something
inherent in the individual
itself. It had to
be due to an outside
stressor, a catastrophic
stressor that
was outside the usual
human experience.
So it could have been
war, *******, ****,
the Holocaust, atomic
bombings, natural
and human-made disasters,
all that versus
ordinary stressors
that we all go through.
In fact, thanks to
the activism of the
Vietnam veterans that
came home from war in
the 70s, and also
women, organizations of
women that came together
that showed a lot of
activism around ******
assault and ****.
The APA responded to
that, and hence the
development of post
-traumatic stress disorder.
Very common likelihood
that we're going
to all experience
or have experience
one traumatic event
over a lifespan.
Men, 60% of men,
less so women.
For women, mostly
****** assault
and child *****.
People exposed to
traumatic events, though
most people do not go
on to develop PTSD.
And if they do, they
don't go on to develop
the full-blown syndrome.
um like pain the
traumatic experience
is filtered through
cognitive and emotional
processes before it can
be appraised as uh
different uh as an extreme
threat um different
people appear to have
different trauma
thresholds some are more
protected from and some
are more vulnerable
to developing clinical
symptoms after an
exposure to an extremely
stressful situation
so the idea of different
trauma thresholds
i think is an important
concept more women
are affected by ptsd
than men uh so what
is trauma you know
trauma is uh an
emotional uh response uh
to a terrible uh event
it's an event that
disrupts your security
uh it's an event it's
an event that sort
of exceeds your your
coping um capacity
um
yeah i'll just go back
here for one second
so i want to talk
a little bit more
of uh trauma so So
that trauma can be a
threat to your life
or the life of a loved
one or someone who's
very close to you.
Your security is
disrupted. It can also
be dehumanizing.
And in fact, another
definition of trauma
is when trauma is
the result of being
made into an object,
a thing. It's a
dehumanizing experience.
So in terms of the
diagnosis of a mental
condition, or if you
experience intrusion,
a negative mood,
dissociation, avoidance,
hyperarousal,
a sort of consolation
of these symptoms
within a month of
a traumatic event.
and also perhaps later
on have flashbacks,
unpredictable emotions,
physical symptoms,
all within that month
of the traumatic
event, but lasting
less than six months,
we call that an acute
stress reaction.
But I want you to
come away with the
concept of post-traumatic
stress reaction,
post-traumatic stress
disorder, which
really looks at what
happens when this goes
on for a period of
more than six months.
And here we're going
to use a case of
a 32-year-old Iraq
war veteran who comes
to your primary
care office, begins
his military career
at 18 years old with
a deployment into
Afghanistan in 2003.
He's had four
tours in Iraq and
Afghanistan, and
he's been involved in
multiple raids and
firefights, and
he's retired from
the military, and
now he's returned
to civilian life.
That's known as
the Criterion A.
That's the stressor,
That they were
exposed to, and
certainly war is one,
death, threatened
death, actual
threatened
serious injury,
or threatened
****** violence.
And here you go, direct
exposure, witnessing,
so you could
witness it. And now
it's further developed
that PTSD could
just be by learning
that a close friend or
relative was exposed
to trauma. If the
event involved actual
threatened death,
it must have been
violent or accidental.
And then another
possible criteria could
be that it could be
repeated or extreme
indirect exposure to
aversive details, right?
so first responders
repeatedly exposed
to that type of
situation professionals
repeatedly exposed
to details of child
***** and a real
disclaimer here does
not include indirect
non-professional
exposure through
electronic media television
movies or pictures
so you would
think maybe a forensic
Like pathologists,
ER doctors,
other professions
who deal with
disasters and
disaster victims,
certainly first
responders,
you know, PTSD, something
that they can
be at risk for.
when questioning your
patients he describes
awakening frequently
feeling like
he's back in the field
even when I'm just
hanging out with
friends at a bar so
that's criteria B the
intrusive symptoms
so A we need that
stressor B we need
intrusive symptoms
and they could
be recurrent and
intrusive memories
They could be
traumatic nightmares.
They could involve marked
physiologic reactivity.
We showed you
that example
with just
reminding patients'
cohort about their
Oklahoma City
*******, what happened
to their heart
rate. There's a
physiologic memory.
And criteria C,
that the patient's
found he's no
longer comfortable
seeing his friends
from his troop.
he's avoiding when
you ask him about
what he feels like
he feels like he's
back in Iraq when
he's in a large crowd
so this comes
under avoidance
and it's sort of
picking and choosing one
of these, two of these
one required of those
and then you
question about the
details of the
raid and he says he
cannot remember
about five minutes
he cannot remember
about five
minutes in the
middle of the event
as you continue to
talk he finds little
pleasure in the hobbies
he used to enjoy
like playing basketball
seeing movies
with friends
criteria D
cognition and mood
two are required
right do they
have a diminished
interest in
significant activities
do they feel
alienated from others
the inability to
recall key features
and you don't you
don't have to memorize
or know all the sub
criteria but it's
important that you
recognize the four
main domains right
which i think we're
going to get to the
fourth right now,
where of arousal and
hypervigilance
and reactivity.
He heard a car
backfire, which made
him jump up and
take off running
down the block.
It felt like his
heart was beating
out of his chest.
These are alterations in
arousal and reactivity.
So we have four
main areas,
right? Re
-experiencing, which are
the flashbacks,
the nightmares,
the recurring intrusive
memories. We have
avoidance, area two,
avoid trauma-related
thoughts, feelings,
objects, people, or places.
We have the
cognition and mood.
right the negative
beliefs about oneself or
the world uh emotional
numbing feeling
alienated consistent
shame or guilt and then
we finally we have
um the alterations
the hyper arousal
hyper reactivity
right there's a
sleep disturbance,
there's difficulty
concentrating,
there's the
person's easily
started, they're
irritable,
they're prone to
angry outbursts.
When asked about how
long he's feeling,
we say that he
says that they've
been present for at
least six months,
seems to be getting
worse, not better.
So here we meet the
time criteria, that
the persistence of
the symptoms is for
more than one month.
So just let me
clarify or correct
maybe what I said
earlier, that for
PTSD, the symptoms have
to last at least
more than one month.
So that puts us over
the top. They don't,
you know, it can be.
It doesn't have to
be for six months. It
just, the criteria,
the cutoff is one
month. The persistence
of symptoms in criteria
is B, C, D, and E.
So just let me
clarify that. Acute
stress disorder,
less than one month.
PTSD, more
than one month.
And the patient comes
to you because he
knows he needs to find
a job, but he can't
seem to find it in
himself to go out for
the interviews. He'd
become very isolated.
So you have all
these symptoms but
the key thing is
that it's affecting
his social occupational
functioning.
It's not that he's
able to experience
all he's doing but
still function great
which would seem
to be inconsistent
to be able to do
that But anyway, they
put in criteria G,
that it has to impact
in a negative way
the functioning.
And just when you thought
there were no more
criteria, the
disturbance is not due to
medications, substances,
or other illnesses.
And in his case, he's
not on medications.
He rarely drinks.
This is not
from recreational
drug use. And
so you decided he
may have PTSD. How
are you going to
assess this further?
You could look
and see if the
person has
dissociative symptoms.
The dissociative symptom
of depersonalization,
feeling that
you're an outside
observer or detached
from himself,
feeling as if this is
not happening to me,
or derealization,
feelings of unreality,
distance or distortion,
sure things are not
real this is more like
a dream now where six
months does come in to
play is that sometimes
you could experience
the stress or trauma
but the full diagnosis
is not met until at
least six months after
the trauma although
the some of the symptoms
the onset may occur
immediately so it's
not unusual it does
happen you know it
doesn't mean that after a
month you get ptsd but
it might be a while so
things might have been
suppressed or things
might have gotten
triggered by additional
loss or stressors so
when the full diagnosis
is not met until at
least six month after.
We call this PTSD with
delayed expression.
We're not really
going to focus on
children with
PTSD at this time,
but there is a
preschool subtype.
So getting into the
primary care arena.
There is a assessment
tool, a screen
for PTSD, and PTSD
screening should
become part of
everyday primary care.
Many patients with
PTSD that go untreated
and undiagnosed, And
primary care is an
opportunity to identify
and screen for PTSD.
So in your life,
have you ever had any
experience that was so
frightening, horrible,
upsetting that in the
past month you had
nightmares, were on God,
felt numb, detached from
others' activities
or your surroundings?
Again, not that you
need to memorize the
screenings, but be aware
of them, be aware of
the content, and use
them, especially if
you're treating a veteran
or someone that's gone
through a recent trauma
in their history.
here we go whether
if the peak if the
screening instrument
is utilized clarify
responses to determine
so this gives you a
script of whether
the patient has had a
traumatic experience
uh you say to them i
noticed from your
answers that you had some
symptoms of stress
at some point uh in
their lives many
people have experienced
extremely distressing
events as combat,
physical or ******
assault, bed, accident.
Sometimes these events
lead to symptoms.
Have you had any
experiences like that?
More script.
I see you've
had nightmares.
Can you give
me an example?
Are the symptoms
disrupted? You've had
these thoughts.
Have they interfered
with your relationships,
your work,
your recreation
or employment?
Well, once
having identified
it, what do we
do to treat?
We use cognitive
behavioral therapy. That's
the most well-studied
form of treatment.
We want to be able
to correct faulty
cognitions, faulty
thoughts, faulty beliefs,
while diminishing
symptoms, attenuating
symptoms through
behavioral exposure.
So treatment includes
cognitive therapy,
exposing, coping
skills training,
And the big examples
of cognitive
behavioral therapy are
prolonged exposure,
CPT, cognitive
processing therapy,
and eye movement
desensitization
and reprocessing, EMDR.
So in prolonged
exposure therapy,
survivors repeat their
experience
through imaging,
imagining, and in
vivo exposure in safe
situations, right? We
maybe go back to an area
or a scenario where
they have some
familiarity or trigger
with being exposed where
something might have
happened or imagining
that and going through
it in their mind,
but reminding them
and keeping them safe.
And trauma through this
way can be reprocessed
and show that it's
less painful and
that the trauma was in
the past and it doesn't
exist now in the
present in terms of
their need to feel
hypervigilant or to protect
themselves. um they
begin with the um
with the therapist
following the uh imaginal
exposure to process
with the clinician the
the emotional response
to the experience
in the safe environment
there's a constant
reassurance of
reminding them that it's
safe now that they're
strong now that they're
capable of kind of
taking them from being
this dehumanized
object, this thing, to
a person with resources
that's empowered.
We combine this with
the psychoeducation
about the common reactions
to trauma. And this
could go on for nine
to 12 weeks, twice a
week for 90-minute
sessions. and it's shown
to be clinically
significantly effective.
Another possibility is
cognitive processing
therapy where the exposure
is achieved through
written accounts of
the traumatic event.
We investigate the
feelings elicited by
the writing experience
and we train the
patients to challenge
faulty beliefs. Why
do they believe
they're vulnerable now?
And it's shown that
either cognitive
processing therapy
or a prolonged
exposure therapy,
either one,
are effective in
reducing symptoms.
And then there's
EMDR, eye movement
desensitization
reprocessing.
It's also thought
of as a cognitive
behavioral therapy
that incorporates what
we call saccadic
eye movements, these
lateral side-to-side
eye movements, or
other bilateral
stimulation like tapping.
And these movements
are believed to help
desensitize the emotional
experience to the
traumatic memory and
facilitate reprocessing
and reducing their
emotional intensity.
Sacchatic eye
movements engage both
hemispheres of the
brain, and it helps
integrate emotional and
rational processing.
And research suggests
these movements mimic
the rapid eye movements
of REM sleep. so the
clinician moves two
fingers the patient's
instructed to produce
a more adaptive thought
about the event and
I think that's common
the idea of producing
an adaptive thought
is something I think
that's common to all
these the prolonged
exposure therapy, the
processing therapy and
the EMDR therapy the idea
of helping the
patient produce a more
adaptive thought about
what's happened to them.
Efficacy remains
uncertain, but it's
now been adopted by
many organizations
as a mainstream
treatment option.
What about the
pharmacotherapies?
For people with PTSD,
especially
combinations of therapy
and medication
are indicated.
FDA approval for
paroxetine and sertraline.
Note some evidence
shows that resilient
patients will respond
more quickly to those.
Other antidepressants
are also used.
Fluoxetine, benlafaxine,
mirtazapine, trazodone.
Pracicin is used
sometimes for the
nightmares that
accompany PTSD, and
there's some research
on that as well.
There are alternative
treatments in terms
of complementary and
alternative medicine,
yoga, acupuncture,
tai chi.
Current studies are
underway. way, no solid
evidence concurrently,
and then mindfulness
-based stress reduction
teaches attending
to the present moment
in a nonjudgmental
accepting way, and
then let's look at
how people do uh
with these treatments
uh well ptsd itself uh
is a chronic condition
sometimes it waxes
and wanes a third
of the patients recover
in a year one third
are asymptomatic
after 10 years we do
see this relationship
between a decreased
uh longevity and uh
and decreased health,
physical health, and
trauma and PTSD, and
the theory that
neurochemical changes occur
in PTSD that have a
biological effect.
So we see patients
with PTSD have comorbid
hypertension and
atherosclerotic disease.
And when follow-up
studies were done
about the National
Vietnam Veterans Survey,
were surveyed, from
initial to follow
-up 30 years later,
Vietnam veterans with
PTSD were twice as
likely to have died.
On imaging,
we see decreased volume,
neuronal integrity,
decreased functional
integrity of
the hippocampus,
and the amygdala, the
fear center of the brain
that positively
is correlated
with the
severity of PTSD.
The amygdala
is hyperactive,
and at the same time, the
hippocampus starts
to shrink the
more chronic the
illness gets.
The smaller the
hippocampus is,
the prefrontal and
prefrontal cortical
areas are shrunken
and less active
and there's less
emotional regulation.
So, inverse relationship
with medial
prefrontal cortex
activity.
Increased
amygdala activity,
decreased functional
integrity of
the hippocampus.
But again, alone,
the neuroimaging
itself is not a
pathognomonic or
a definitive
biomarker for PTSD.
And there's ongoing
research being studied
for what can be
biomarkers for the
disease. And neurobiological
changes observed
in PTSD research
include looking at
the hypothalamic
pituitary adrenyl access
dysregulation, looking
at glutamatergic
release, decreased
serotonergic release,
thyroid function
disturbance, and increased
sympathetic nervous
system response.
There are some
interesting research and
additional treatments
that are going on for
PTSD, and they include
new studies looking at
transcranial magnetic
stimulation, virtual
reality exposure, deep
brain stimulation,
and then actually
using these
psychogenic
hallucinogenic medications
with assisted exposure
psychotherapy.
And include
using MDMA with
assisted psychotherapy,
ketamine,
psilocybin, and CBD.
And there's some
interesting research,
if you want to
look in the issue of
JAMA, for references
to what's happening
in those areas.
So, in summary,
a majority of people
will experience
trauma over
their lifetime.
That's sometimes
hard to avoid.
There can be serious
social, emotional,
occupational, and health
implications in the
development of PTSD.
A key to understanding
PTSD is identifying
patients through
screening, treating
them appropriately.
We have good
treatments, the
cognitive behavioral
treatments, using also
FDA-approved medications,
certain of the
antidepressants. and
then a wide body
of research exists.
Novel treatments that
are being researched
right now to address
this very serious
concern. The key to the
future is identifying
what makes a person
vulnerable or resilient.
And that concludes
the PTSD lecture.